well be this very exciting I wanted to
do this for years to do an edition of
our rubber time just for the foreign
audience I must say that something
personal in it I am actually going to be
touring in Europe next year I'm going to
be playing London Amsterdam Oslo and
Stockholm so so and this is a great
panel for that general you are familiar
with cultures you bombed many of them so
these are just stories you will arm in
any eye you know you are right I'm a
bomb it's true I've never done this
before I'm nervous as hell but you know
what I want to do it before I'm dead
okay so here are some stories there was
a front-page story in The New York Times
this week on the resurgence of
anti-semitism in Europe oh yes why does
this issue keep coming up that's yeah it
was very disturbing to read that that in
so many capitals in Europe I read that
you know people are standing in front of
synagogues and saying just the Jews I
mean this is the continent that fought a
war to stop Hitler 70 years ago well two
reasons one a lot of Muslims there
especially in France and in Germany so
that's one problem and then you also
have that small minority of Europeans
and France and Germany have never gone
away who are still very racist and
anti-semitic that's a problem there's
still problem with the neo-nazis - I
mean right and I was just in Berlin and
some of the things that Hitler had built
that they're trying to either tear down
or disguise with gardens because the
neo-nazis now are holding them up as
shrines so I don't think that ever
totally left it certainly isn't a
majority but there's a rise in that now
it's troublesome it is troublesome okay
rabbi cash-money asked the panel
I think this is from Australia I often
hear that the USA is great because of
quote our freedom what freedoms do you
have that other countries for example
Australia doesn't that's a good question
yeah no I hear that often uh and why
don't they get bombed as much for them
yeah um Marco Rubio used to say in his
in his stump speech he is to have this
line about how this is the only country
in the world America where an idea that
started out on a cocktail napkin could
wind up being traded on the stock
exchange and I was like no other
countries have napkins a stock exchange
is ready what world are they living in
but it is a good question I mean we do
that often in this country especially on
the right talk only in America and it's
really not only in America I mean we do
have maybe more freedom on some issues I
do know Europeans who have come to this
country because they find the economics
over there too stifling that is true and
Australia is I've much much freer than
eyes this in many ways but we are the
one country the one indispensable
country right now that protects freedom
around the globe and I think that that's
yeah you can make the case that
Australia they're probably freer but
we're the ones that defend their freedom
so we're safe
we're the cops you're saying uh if not
the cops the bouncers
so you're saying Australia is free
Australia is a great country I love it
oh yeah you should go tour there you are
gonna get into so much trouble when you
get back to wash no it's great girls
great couple
really all right there's a country freer
than us and you love it I am I think you
I wouldn't want to be at your Bible
meeting of this is from Frankfurt
Germany what habit or way of life from
any foreign country do you believe your
fellow citizens should adopt and could
benefit from well I'll answer that first
because when we left for vacation on
August 1st I said I was applauding the
fact that Europeans take all all of
August off I think Americans have too
little vacation time they're too
stressed out they put way too much
emphasis on material goods as opposed to
enjoying life in addition I think we
could have smarter gun policies I think
that that is just absolutely it's just
ridiculous what we're right we're doing
and and it's not even the fact that I
don't think that people should have guns
I grew up in Louisiana it's a gun
culture we hunted all the time people
had guns around diet I don't think
there's anything wrong with that but the
actual proliferation of so many guns to
the point where you now have almost a
gun for a person in this country well
the and guns outlive their owners if you
take care of it's not like you're gonna
evaporate or go away or stop being
functional and they're just gonna keep
be more more guns and at a certain point
well that's the problem let me let me
finish you with what you said yeah
because you said you know we have to
hunt this is the problem but you know
the Democrats basically love guns not
quite as much as Republicans but they
they basically say well we can all agree
that murdering animals is something we
absolutely have to do
and you know when you're into shooting
living things well I mean it is a
slippery I think you can take that
position I think that but and you get
joy out of doing that something about
joy isn't it but it is Eugene I teach a
sport it's what they were saying I'm not
talking about we need guns for sport are
talking about sport shooting every sport
for the and I'm literally talking about
I think is there a sport if you don't
know what game is on and you don't have
the same equipment I didn't think it's
released I thought he was a liberal on
the pad ever a problem for liberals and
and enroll liberals and pretty
particularly the ones who live in the
south we had we have different kind of
concepts of unlist on this subject and I
think that right I live in New York City
I don't see why anybody should have a
gun in York City I personally they're
cops everywhere and I can your pick up
911 and somebody be at my door in five
seconds when you live out in the middle
yes I live in one of those neighborhoods
so that's fine but but if you live where
I grew up there are no cops there's
literally no cops and if you call the
cop there would they would be there 30
seconds from now and what are you doing
that in that intervening time Wow so I
think that there is a difference
that's regional this is from Slovenia
how much danger or how many deaths
should free nations absorb to protect
civil liberties I love this first of all
this is a this is a very good question
but it's phrased in a way we would never
say it in America and it's true there is
certain amount of deaths that we would
have to absorb to protect it how many
death should free nations absorb to
protect civil liberties it's it's real
you can't have absolute on both well
twice you are Slovenia you have stumped
the panel you
when a dinner at Chili's I think it's a
great question and I think it's a
question that goes to balance and how do
we balance our liberties with our
freedoms against threats of terror and
you know sometimes we go way too
overboard which we've done in our
history periodically and then we go the
other way and you know that's a balance
though I defined we've just seen the
deaths of two journalists from the
United States I mean that represents
freedom of speech freedom of the press
they were out there doing their jobs and
I think as you saw each beheading you
saw the American support for taking
action grow even though they were in
numbers it was obviously that's that's
exactly right to people who purposely
went there they purposely swam in the
crocodile pool and got eaten by
crocodiles should we then spend I don't
know how much money ten million ten
billion ten trillion dollars to to
revenge that it just seems like perhaps
it's not a good balance the piece were
journalists I don't think they were out
there to find a way to make money I mean
they were seeking truth I mean they
would they agree but they were seeking
the truth in a place that they knew was
the most dangerous place in the world
does that mean we have an obligation
than to spend unlimited amounts of blood
that's direct what's the life of an
American worth well well I mean that's
an almost something but not everything
yeah I don't know it's worth everything
oh you know and we have to just go to
DEFCON five any time an American gets
killed under any circumstances anywhere
no but I think we we protect it but you
know I think it's part of our obligation
to protect American lives wherever they
may be our own well-being
the existential threats that may be to
our nation but an American life want to
be precious to us but but but we operate
a different variety every sick people
die every single day in Harlem right I
don't know why we care so I mean I agree
let's taste it coz shoe-bomber
won because every time we go to the
airport right you get to fly private but
the rest of us have to take our shoes
off every single time we go through the
airport so every time you I go to the
airport I think he won but and and and
our horizons are different right which
is we want vengeance now we want to be
over quick
but their horizon is a decade a century
and like they're not playing on our like
quick you bombing now and you and you
win tomorrow and it's gonna be over and
I'm gonna let it go and it's gonna be
done that's not how they're playing this
game and I am have flown private I don't
get to fly let me honey you let me at
least say some real quick you had a
wonderful soliloquy about the evils of
Islam about the the worst parts of it
you know if you're gonna stop some of
the worst elements of that you can't you
play by that Marcus of Queensbury rules
you have to you have to fight them we
and fight them hard and I think that the
idea that we can just lay down and not
fight Isis is very my naive and exactly
examines what you were saying in your
speech do we got to stop them what does
it write them hard mean to you know that
means to bomb them when they are making
these advancements and creating safety
so we can win it from the ears what
you're saying
I don't want boots on the ground I think
I think we can contain this head we have
okay consider me boots what we have like
Intel military intelligence on we have
this is just a hoax when we say there's
no boots on the ground there are
American military intelligence on the
ground okay I have time for one fake one
more Marc Vaughn work I'm asked the
panel why has the NSA scandal not lead
to any change anywhere regards from
Munich what
that's funny through Munich please you
know I always think Americans know one
lesson from history Munich everybody we
hate is Hitler and any but time we don't
completely throw down at full force
against everybody who looked at us the
wrong way we are repeaters who are
replaying Munich with Hitler but I don't
think we're listening in on Merkel's
phone calls anymore so that's probably
one change
maybe not why were we ever lucky her
lucky no but I think he means here at
home you know why hasn't the NSA scandal
led to any change but yeah I don't know
if that's true because certainly the
releases from Snowden prompted the
Congress here in America to take up this
issue in a way they never had before and
you saw some pretty strange bedfellows
in Congress who were allied on the idea
that you know what maybe you don't have
to spy on Americans to that degree and
to keep the data forever and to provide
oversight right but you know to get back
to your question I don't think bombing
is what has stopped America from being
attacked again I think it's more what
the NSA is doing what law enforcement do
I think that's right spy is I think it's
all of it I think I think I think part
of bombing creates terrorists that these
other agencies that have to stop I'm not
always I don't know okay thank you very
much overseas edition I'll see you in
May 2015